(indistinct audience chattering)
(gentle music)
- So I've wanted to be a nurse since,
I think I was about four years old.
My dad actually had a
pretty serious back injury
when I was young,
and so he spent a lot of time in the ICU
and I remember the nurses there
made me feel so comfortable
and I realized, hey,
I want to be the person to
make others feel comfortable.
- Coming from an immigrant family,
I was really interested in really changing
how we talk about mental health
and also talking about the
opportunities that I have
to destigmatize mental
health in my community,
so that was really important to me.
- As a nurse, I get this
incredible privilege.
It's completely transformed me.
I've grown in confidence,
I've grown in self-awareness.
I've grown to understand
what my purpose is
and the population in
which I want to practice.
- Nursing allows us to have a unique
and intimate look into people's lives.
- I don't just wanna be a
provider, I wanna lead people.
And I believe at Yale,
I get the opportunities to learn
how to be the right type
of leader I wanna become,
but I wanna do it on a national level.
Whatever I'm doing in 10
years could be for the CDC,
could be for the White House,
you're gonna see my name
and they're gonna know
I went to Yale.
- I think of nursing as
the family profession.
My mother was a nurse, but you know,
my grandfather was a nurse.
After his little store on the
lower East side of New York
was wiped out in the depression,
he then developed a profession
of caring for elderly
and ill individuals.
- My wife's a nurse.
I have a very strong sense of
what it means to be a nurse.
It is an altruistic work of serving people
in moments when they
are most need of help.
And so when I think of the nursing school,
I think of the service that they render
to all parts of our community.
During Covid, every one of the
people that gave me a vaccine
was somebody who was a student
at the Yale Nursing School.
We support the nurses and
the nurses support us,
and that service makes a huge
difference to the communities
in which we live.
- So Yale's primary purpose
is to improve the world today
and for future generations.
That is a mission of every
nurse who graduates from Yale.
They do it by leading organizations,
they do it through advanced practice,
they do it through clinical service,
they do it through nursing education,
they do it through science,
but they are all focused
on improving the world.
That's what Yale is all about.
That's what the Yale School
of Nursing is all about.
- You come to nursing because
you have this incredible need
to be part of humanity
and to bring health to all
kinds of different people.
- The ability to be a nurse,
be a nurse practitioner, be a mom,
and also inspire the next
generation of nurses.
I mean, that's huge.
- We bring dedication
and passion for the work
alongside of this desire
to bring change to the system
at large and to open ourselves
to approaching healthcare
from different perspectives.
- What I see is just such an
exciting view of the future,
of what they want to do, right?
And how much they want to take on,
and how much they want to
improve health for all.
This is the call of nursing.
- The ability to impact change,
the ability to conduct
research that is important
not only to myself, but also to the health
and wellbeing of others.
- We need to be thinking
about not just illness,
but wellness. And not just wellness,
but what does it mean for a person
in the context of their life.
- What we're looking
for in the next century
is who we are continuing to become.
And that is what makes
this place ever exciting.
- I'm just passionate about
educating the next generation
of nurses.
We have varieties of opportunities
to make some transformational impact
all the way across the world.
- YSN in one word.
- Pioneering.
- Impactful.
- Trailblazing.
- Exciting.
- Empowering.
- Inspirational.
- It's leadership.
- The people.
- Unique.
- Community.
- Integrity.
- Resilient.
- Opportunities.
- Innovation.
- It's where tradition and
innovation across each other
and come together to
contribute to the betterment
of our society.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
- Good afternoon and welcome
to the official kickoff
of the Yale School of Nursing
Centennial Celebration.
I am Melissa Galinato,
a member of the Centennial
Planning Committee
and a second year pediatric
nurse practitioner
primary care student.
It is an honor to be
the first to welcome you
to this exciting moment
in the school's history
and to introduce President Salovey.
On behalf of my nursing
and midwifery classmates,
I like to say what a
remarkable achievement
it is to be here.
Given the diversity of our backgrounds
and unique experiences,
I look forward to witnessing
how we collectively contribute
to the advancement of YSN's mission
of better health for all people.
When I, along with the
rest of class of 2024,
graduate in the spring,
we'll follow nearly 6,000 alumni
into all aspects of healthcare.
MSN graduates will become clinicians
in every imaginable care setting.
Our doctor of nursing
practice degree recipients
will lead health systems and
influence healthcare policy.
Those of us who earn a PhD
will continue to teach the
next generation of providers
through interprofessional
education, research, and practice.
It is clear YSN alumni have
and will continue to innovate,
lead and transform healthcare in ways
not unimaginable for
nurses a hundred years ago.
And now it is my privilege to introduce
the 23rd president of Yale, Peter Salovey.
President Salovey has both celebrated
and championed YSN's mission
and our values in nursing and midwifery.
In the summer,
he attended the disaster simulation
for our first year GPEN students
and eagerly delved into conversations
to learn about the students'
intense experiences.
President Salovey firmly
believes in the impact
of our chosen paths,
so much so that he and his loved ones
endowed his Salovey Family
Nursing Scholarship here at Yale
or at Yale School of Nursing.
It is a privilege to have
such a dedicated advocate
for YSN in the top position
at this university,
and we welcome his presence
here today as a testament
to YSN's integral role
in shaping Yale's future.
I invite you to read the
rest of his formal biography
in our program and allow him to share more
about his commitment to supporting YSN.
I would now like to welcome to
the podium President Salovey.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much.
Well, thank you very much
for that kind introduction.
I very much appreciate it.
And good afternoon everyone.
So nice to see you all
and all supporting the
school in its hundredth year.
It's an enormous pleasure to
be part of the great history
of the Yale School of Nursing,
and I very much have been looking forward
to this centennial moment.
I'm also delighted that with us today,
our Yale School of Nursing faculty,
Yale School of Nursing
staff members, students,
alumni who are now practitioners,
other educators, other researchers.
I'm delighted you all with us today.
And I'm especially delighted
that our new dean has arrived,
Azita Emami.
And so we give her-
(audience applauding)
Ann, it's so great to see you as well.
And that perfect time for a handoff
is at the hundred year mark, right?
(audience laughing)
98, not enough.
102, maybe too many a hundred is perfect.
A hundred is perfect.
I'm also delighted that
Rajiv Shah is with us
from the Rockefeller Foundation.
He'll make some remarks in a few moments,
but it's very meaningful
for us to have him here
with us because the Rockefeller Foundation
was here right from the beginning.
He'll tell you a little bit
more about that history.
But it was gifts from the
Rockefeller Foundation
that essentially allowed
Yale to create this school.
Well, 1923, a hundred years
ago, what was happening,
the foundation, Rockefeller
Foundation's Goldmark report
suggested that a transformation
in nursing education
was needed.
The word they used to
describe nursing education
up to that time was inadequate.
Not that's the word they used,
the report wasn't inadequate.
And in partnership with
the Rockefeller Foundation,
early nursing leaders
like Dean Annie Goodrich
set out to make this the solution,
make Yale the solution
to those inadequacies
in nursing education.
So we became the first school
to offer a full educational experience
for nurses in training
rather than an apprenticeship program.
The curriculum that Dean Goodrich
and others pulled together
talked about future nurses,
and this is amazing that
this is a hundred years ago,
this language, future nurses
as scientifically informed,
technically expert, and
socially experienced, right?
It still sounds like
exactly what we do today
in the school of Nursing.
And in fact,
there's a whole history
of nursing leadership
that came from this school.
I won't go over it with you.
I'll just mention one Dean Florence Wald,
who brought the hospice
movement from England
to the United States.
I mention it because Branford Hospice
celebrates its 50th
anniversary this same year
that we celebrate our one hundredths.
When Yale opened admission for students
with a bachelor's degree,
but no prior background in nursing
through what is now called GPEN,
the graduate entry pre specialty
program, that was a first.
By 1975, Yale School of Nursing
has 10 specialty programs and tracks
was at the vanguard of
the nurse practitioner
and new nurse midwifery
educational movement
at the graduate level.
Fast forward a hundred years
forward and nursing is making,
the school of nursing is making
all kinds of contributions
across the university,
let me pick just one.
As many of you know,
we have a planetary solutions initiative.
The Planetary Health Initiative
within Planetary Solutions
is a touch point for
the school of nursing.
How to essentially deal with
the way in which climate change
is affecting human health.
When I think about the next
century of the Yale School
of Nursing, I'm optimistic,
I think nursing's centrality
to this university
and nursing as a profession centrality
to improving the world now
and for the future is
just all too obvious.
So in the film you heard about my family,
I sometimes say nursing
was the family business
in our family.
My former brother-in-law was
a nurse, you heard about that.
My grandfather's story is interesting.
After he was wiped out in the depression,
when my grandfather used to
talk about being wiped out,
he had a little store that was
maybe about 500 square feet
and it went bankrupt in the depression.
But he didn't have anything
to begin with really.
(audience laughing)
So that was on the lower
East side of New York.
And as you heard, to make a living,
he just cared for people and
he had no formal education.
But in those days, on the
testimony of your clients,
you could get a license as an LPN
and I always used to joke, I actually,
I have it, but I used to say
my grandfather was New
York State LPN number two
or something like that.
(audience laughing)
He had to have been one of the first men
to be licensed as an LPN.
But he was, and he
talked about his patients
and he talked about what he had learned
kind of in the trenches of
nursing all my childhood.
And so my mother who
married into that family,
and he always had a special relationship,
'cause my mother as
you heard, was a nurse.
She went to what is formerly
called Jewish Hospital
and Medical Center of Brooklyn,
but everybody calls it Brooklyn Jewish,
doesn't exist anymore.
And had that old style of RN education
that wasn't university based
and was more apprentice oriented.
But my childhood,
I was a latchkey child because
we came home from school,
my brother and I, and we
made ourselves a snack
and we waited for our mom to
come home from the hospital
where she was working with a practice
where she was working,
ultimately she moved
into geriatric nursing
toward the last maybe 20
years of her profession
and was the director of
nurses at geriatric hospitals
first in, well, by that
time we'd left New Jersey,
we were now in Buffalo, New
York, and later in Los Angeles.
The stories that my grandfather told
that my brother-in-law
told, that my mother told,
made an impression on
all of us in my family.
And helped us, I think
appreciate how rewarding
a profession can be.
And I know our students feel that way,
but also how complex it is.
And I would say in more recent years,
how in need of improvement
our healthcare system is.
Well, it was the public health
crisis ushered in by Covid,
that I think helped every
one of us who is not a nurse,
or a public health
professional like my wife is,
or a physician helped
all of us who are not
in the health professions
truly appreciate,
truly appreciate how hard this work is,
how needed this work is,
and how in short supply this work is.
We're still recovering.
We're not out of the pandemic
and further we're still
recovering from the effect
that the pandemic had on our workforce
in the health professions.
And so a hundredth anniversary comes,
you don't plan it for a particular time,
it comes in the hundredth year,
but the university's response
to the hundredth anniversary,
the fact that we are
matching gifts to the school,
the idea that we are celebrating
the centrality of the school,
I think is not an accident
in coming in these years
as we recover as a society
from this global pandemic.
While everyone who is here today
has been involved in helping
position in some way,
the Yale School of Nursing at
the center of Yale University
and help reposition the profession
as at the center of healthcare,
as delivered in this country
and throughout the world.
And I thank you for all of that hard work,
and I thank you for letting me be a part
of both today's celebration,
but this larger mission and
these larger goals as well.
So thank you all very
much for being here today
and congratulations to the school.
(audience applauding)
Thank you. Now I'd like to
introduce our next speaker,
who is the Yales school
of Nursing's new dean,
Dr. Azita Emami.
So Azita is an internationally
recognized nursing leader,
a nursing investigator.
She's had a career dedicated
to fostering wellness.
She's had two more, than
two decades in leading
research and teaching
in university settings.
This is not, what's the expression?
This is not your first rodeo.
This is her third deanship.
And we are so fortunate that she can build
on Ann's accomplishments and lead us
into the next century of nursing at Yale,
that she responded when I
called her and asked her,
would you like a third deanship?
And she ultimately said yes.
Her work has focused quite a
bit on the social determinants
that affect health and wellness
as a part-time health psychologist
that appeals to me greatly.
She's a trustee of the Robert
Wood Johnson Foundation.
She's been an advocate for
health equity and accessibility
for quality health care for
all people, and in fact,
quality healthcare beyond
the nursing profession.
I know she is the right leader
for the school's second century.
So please join me in
welcoming her to the podium.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much,
President Salovey for
those very kind words.
And good afternoon everyone.
It's such a pleasure to be with you today.
I would like to begin
by land acknowledgement
to initiate our conversation.
Yale School of Nursing
is situated on the land
of the past and present Quinnipiac people.
It is with deep gratitude that
we honor the land, people,
history and traditions
of the indigenous peoples
who stewarded and the land for generations
and who are still connected to the land,
as well as the responsibility
that comes with sharing the land.
We acknowledge the painful
history and with our mission
at Yale School of Nursing of
better health for all people,
we embrace the commitment
to health, justice,
and care for all communities,
especially those who suffer
unacceptable health disparities.
So a centennial celebration
honors the past,
but it also is an appropriate occasion
to envision the future that
will be built on that past.
I want to take a few moments
today to share with you
the future I see for the school of nursing
and how the past makes
that future possible.
I see a future where nursing leads the way
on promoting wellness rather than focusing
and addressing illnesses.
I see a future where better
health for all people
becomes a reality.
My vision of the future
sees the healthcare system
in which everyone feels
comfortable, respected,
welcome and understood,
because we have educated nurses
to create that environment.
My vision of the future
sees vastly improved access
to healthcare,
because nurses are
practicing to the full scope
of their capabilities, including delivery,
delivering urgently needed primary care
to historically underserved populations.
And perhaps most importantly,
I see a future in which our
advocacy result in addressing
the many social determinants of health
that are the root cause
of disparities in outcomes
and the lack of wellness for many people.
These disparities are not new,
nor will they be easily eliminated.
These are deeply entrenched realities
reflecting the structural
and systemic inequities
resulting from racism,
classism, and inequitable access
to the resources people
need to live and thrive.
At Yale School of Nursing,
we are the heirs to a
legacy of innovation,
creativity, and advocacy.
Yale School of Nursing was
founded as a break from the past
as President Salovey shared with you.
For the first time, Nursing
was an academic discipline
with its own body of knowledge
to be taught and mastered.
Nurses were no longer just
a source of cheap labor
for the medical wards,
they were now educated to provide care
that enable people to get better.
This was, believe me or not,
a groundbreaking concept.
Our first dean, Annie Goodrich,
was the first female dean at Yale.
We were among the first nursing schools
to grant a master's degree
and to require prior nursing
experience to admission.
In the 1970s, we introduced
the idea of graduate entry,
pre specialty nursing GPEN program.
And at that point of time,
just thinking about making a non-nurse,
an advanced nurse
practitioner in three years,
it was something that
no one would believe in
to be accomplished, but we did it.
Our legacy of leadership continues today,
mostly recently with the launch
of the brand new online MSN program.
Yale School of Nursing
began breaking barriers
at its inception and has
never stopped doing so.
We will continue adding
to that admirable legacy
as we enter our new century.
I believe there is a widespread consensus
that the American healthcare system
is not delivering optimal results.
There's less consensus
about how to make it better.
Well, the short answer is nurses.
As one of the leading schools of nursing,
we have an opportunity and an obligation
to educate the nurses who
will lead in creating change
and delivering better
health for all people.
Yale School of Nursing
was a paradigm shift
at its inception.
And we will be that once
again in our second century.
Our nurse graduates will
continue being compassionate,
capable clinicians.
They will also be powerful,
persuasive advocates,
inquisitive, accomplished researchers,
inspirational educators, capable
and creative policy makers,
respected and respectful
community members,
and above all else,
leaders in redefining what wellness is
and how it can be made
the standard of care.
Today's theme is
imagining the next century
of better health for all people.
I want to do more than just imagining it.
I want to make it happen by
leading a school of nursing
that shares a vision of
a future of wellness,
equitable access to healthcare
and a system of care
that lives up to promises of equity made
at this country's foundation.
Make no mistake,
getting to that goal is
a very challenging task.
But for a century,
Yale School of Nursing has identified
and met challenges in healthcare.
It's who we are and it's what we do.
We can thank our
predecessors for the legacy
and we can best honor them
by committing to following
in their footsteps and
looking forward, not away.
We cannot accept as
insurmountable the divisions
and equities of lack of wellness
that are today's reality in our country.
We cannot accept that healthcare
disparities are inevitable,
and we absolutely cannot
accept that the idea,
the idea that meeting,
the meeting and eliminating
these challenges
is too costly or too difficult.
Nursing is American's
most trusted profession.
Tens of millions of
people are counting on us
to create a new healthcare
system in this country
to focus on improving
the health of all people.
We are the voice and advocates
for those who have no voices.
We are Yale School of Nursing.
We will be the clinicians and advocates
and voices that inspire a transformation
in Americans health.
So thank you very much and
welcome to the next century
of Yale School of Nursing.
(audience applauding)
It's now my real pleasure to
introduce our special guest,
Dr. Rajiv Shah is president
of the Rockefeller Foundation,
which made the grant,
as you heard previously,
that established Yale School
of Nursing centuries ago.
The Rockefeller Foundation
believed in advanced
nurse practice for nurses
when the concept didn't even
exist, no one knew about it.
So very pioneering, very, very innovative.
And the foundation continues to identify
and support transformative changes
across human and planetary health.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Shah.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
Good afternoon everyone. How are you?
- [Audience] Good.
- Just outta curiosity,
how many students are here?
Oh, good.
Well, thank you for
being here in particular
and for taking on the
mission you're taking on.
Thank you President Salovey
for that outstanding set of remarks
and for sharing with
us why you care so much
and have in your family for generations.
And thank you Dean Emami for
inaugurating the new century
for this great school and for
your extraordinary leadership
that I know will help this
school reach even higher heights.
So it's really exciting to be here
and it's great to be with this community.
And to honor a little bit
of our shared history.
In many ways,
the Rockefeller Foundation
and the Yale School of Nursing
were founded for the same reason,
effectively to use science
and the frontiers of science
to improve the health of everyone.
And in fact,
before the foundation was
even incorporated in 1913,
John D. Rockefeller Sr. gave
more than a million dollars
to try to eradicate
hookworm a treatable disease
that affected, remember this number,
more than 40% of people
living in the American South.
The result of that work,
which created an
infrastructure at the time
called the General Education Board,
resulted in creating America's
county-based public health
infrastructure.
That work also provided the basic protocol
for the Rockefeller Foundation's
global public health campaigns,
which began thereafter
and targeted a number
of important infectious diseases.
The goal of those campaigns
were all about making health
and the access to health more equitable,
in particular for vulnerable communities.
Back then, the definition
of vulnerable community
was very large,
because the application
of science in medicine,
in nursing and in public
health was haphazard
and unorganized.
And while I am not the
author, as you can tell,
of the original report the
president made reference to,
I think the indictment of
medicine and the health sciences
at the turn of the last century
was that it was not a
science-based discipline.
And the foundation worked with
institutions across the world
to create a science-based discipline.
Within all of the extraordinary inequities
that existed in health
in the United States
and around the world at that time,
nurses were a bright spot.
We've heard about Annie Goodrich
and the extraordinary history she's had,
but I am new to her story.
And so it was fun for me to learn
that she became a nurse before
the turn of the century.
And as nursing superintendent,
when the first World War broke out,
she warned that the US
Army was deeply unprepared
and it would lead to significant
competitive disadvantage.
As a result,
she was chosen to organize and lead
the Army School of Nursing
as its first ever dean,
for which she received the
distinguished service medal,
probably the first nurse
to receive that medal.
After her service to the Army,
she of course came here and
founded this amazing school.
The Yale School of Nursing
under her leadership
was founded with a
$150,000 five year grant
from the Rockefeller Foundation.
(audience laughing)
I asked President Salovey,
if he could start a
school today for $150,000.
He said no.
(audience laughing)
And we did a little math and we learned
that we think that's
about 2.7 or $2.8 million
in today's money.
And just a few years later,
at the end of that grant,
when the foundation reviewed
the progress of the mission,
which was bringing science
and educational discipline
and lifting up the baseline
education process for nurses
and nursing, they decided
it was so successful,
they awarded another $1 million endowment,
which really allowed
the school to flourish.
We think that's about $18
million in today's money.
I also asked the president,
if you could start a school
today for 18 million,
he said, no.
(audience laughing)
So Yale and the foundation
learned together
that nursing was in fact
the key to public health
in the United States
in that window of time.
To me, that's a lesson
that I think is extraordinarily
relevant today for,
I know how many of you as students here
have put your efforts and
energies into global health,
which is where the foundation spends
a lot of its resources today.
And we've seen over the
last 15 or 20 years,
extraordinary progress.
Just to give you one example
about the turn of the century,
around 2000,
there were about nine
to 10 million children
under the age of five who died every year,
mostly of easily preventable causes
and almost entirely in developing nations.
That number was effectively cut in half
until about a few years ago
and has been steadily creeping up
each of the last few years.
And the truth is, this week is,
we call it Climate Week,
or the Sustainable Development
Goals week in New York
at the United Nations.
And it's been pretty grim
to look at the numbers
because over the last few years,
we are systematically unwinding years,
even decades of progress
in fighting hunger,
fighting poverty,
and certainly in our common mission
of standing up for health equity
and international public health.
And so now more than ever,
we have to recognize that
nurses are, once again,
have always been a
bright spot in the fight
from those of you who
helped vaccinate migrant,
transgender and other vulnerable
people against Covid 19
in India,
to those who are tracking
maternal and newborn health,
using new digital tools in Uganda,
to those who administered
PCR tests to Afghan refugees
right here in New Haven.
Your point of service,
point of leadership and points of science
are the hopes we have for
changing the status of health
and public health at home
and around the world.
That insight, which was
true many, many years ago,
is still true today.
And so it's a real honor
to get to be with you
and celebrate your history.
And it's even more
exciting to get to be here
and participate in a conversation
where we'll talk about your future,
because I believe now more than ever
with the pace of technology,
the pace of science,
new tools related to
artificial intelligence
and new realities about a
society slowly but steadily,
opening up to include everybody,
what this school has stood for,
its values, its commitments, its science,
and its people will be
more transformational
in this century to come. Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- I think that our microphones
are on. Do you hear us well?
Okay, great.
So I would like to begin
by thanking both of you
for your very powerful
inspirational remarks.
And thank you very much
for being with us today
to discuss very important topic
that I think that's many of us
are very interested to learn more about.
So before we start our conversation,
I just would like to share with you that,
after our conversation
there will be opportunities
for the audience to ask questions.
So while we are carrying
out our conversation,
please start thinking
about what are the topics
that you would like to ask
our special guests here today?
Yeah. I would like to begin
with my first questions
to both of you.
A hundred years ago,
the Rockefeller Foundation
founded the Yale School of
Nursing at the first academic,
as the first academic nursing
school in this country.
We are honored to be here
a hundred years later
talking about the importance
of how this workforce
has evolved and progressed.
So for each of you,
what is the most surprising
change you have witnessed,
or heard about in the
profession of nursing?
Who would like to start?
- I'm happy to start. I,
you know, I get to see,
I ran a federal agency called
USAID for President Obama,
US Agency for International Development.
And so I've had a chance to see nursing
and the practice of nursing
in societies around the world.
And the thing I find is that
the secret transformation
that's happening is if you go to a village
in northern India,
or a slum outside of Nairobi,
where some of us just were a
few weeks ago called Cabera,
you'll meet nurses who are
taking their smartphones
and an extraordinary amount
of technology with them
to the interface with patients.
And it is transforming their capacity
to address malnutrition,
to identify disease,
to rapidly determine how
to triage communities
and making them frankly,
ever more powerful and
ever more successful.
There's an outstanding long piece today
and or yesterday maybe
in the "New York Times"
about the community health workers,
which of course are not
anywhere near the high level
of Yale educated school
of nursing graduates.
But I think there's going
to be a trend over time
with the democratization
of knowledge, information,
and technology at the point of service
and the point of care,
so that over time we'll
finally be able to reach
absolutely everyone with the
ethic and spirit of nursing
with which the school was founded,
which is the country at the
time needed 50,000 nurses,
had 11,000,
and was asking itself how
could you quickly generate
40,000 additional super skilled,
highly trained professionals.
I think that's the kind
of thinking we need today
in countries around the world,
if we're to turn around the
reality that we're losing ground
on fighting malaria, deaths,
or dealing with under five mortality,
or have an increase in neonatal
mortality in many settings.
And even just dealing with
the extraordinary disparities
in this country that dean,
you mentioned in your
opening part of your remarks.
So that's the thing I'm
both most excited about
and most surprised by is how pervasive
that access to technology is going to be
when it really hits.
- Thank you.
- So let me answer that question
in a little different way,
and I don't know if
surprise is the emotion,
but certainly surprise and thrilled
is the emotion that I feel
when I think about this.
So when I was an undergraduate,
I took a class called medical sociology.
And one of the interesting
aspects of medical sociology
as taught in the 1970s
was a set of experiments,
field experiments done mostly
in the 50 and early 60s
on status and the health
professionals, health professions.
And they typically set
up a situation in which
a nurse would discover
in a hospital setting
that a physician had ordered
the wrong dose of a medication
or had, you know, set out
or delivered the wrong dose.
And in various ways,
there's a whole set of
experiments in various ways,
the question was,
would the nurse confront
the physician and say,
you've got the wrong drug here,
you've got the wrong
amount of this drug here.
And in the 1950s, again and again,
what was demonstrated
is the nurses all knew
there was a mistake and many
of them didn't say anything.
And this was taught in health,
in the sociology of health
as an example of status
and status characteristics.
Some of it was gendered, some
of it was professional status,
and how it could lead
the status consciousness
could lead to mistakes in healthcare.
What's wonderful and surprising
isn't the right word,
but thrilling is you couldn't
replicate those studies today.
You couldn't get that result today,
the way in which nurses are
incorporated as equal members
of a team, respected as a profession,
and are expected to say, sorry, doc,
you don't have that right.
I saw it myself when I
was a psychology intern
at the West Haven VA Hospital
just a couple of decades later.
And that says a lot about the profession,
it says a lot about education,
it says a lot about the kinds of people
attracted to nursing.
It says a lot about gender equality
and I think it's a, of course,
results in the delivery of
safer and better healthcare
for everyone.
- Great answers, thank you.
The next question is
to all of us actually,
and I would like to answer it first.
(audience laughing)
- Good idea.
- Following your delighted surprise.
(all laughing)
So what is the one baseline
improvement you see as critical
to better health in the United States
and then internationally?
And I have been thinking
about it for a long time,
and I would like to say that
the most critical baseline,
based on my opinion,
is a universal healthcare
access to everyone
through affordable care
and with a very sharp focus on prevention,
health promotion that will be done
through very strong primary care
and of course delivered by nurses.
So what about you?
- Yeah, you know,, I would
answer in a very similar way.
There is no doubt that the
economics of healthcare
would be improved dramatically
if we put more emphasis on prevention.
And you know, as a psychologist,
I know that as a nurse professional,
many of you know that
the most expensive things to thing to do
is to fix problems after they happen
rather than prevent them.
And so the emphasis on
behavior, and lifestyle factors,
and environmental factors,
and the prevention of
illness before it happens
is partly what's going to, I think save
our healthcare system in this country.
So I, you know,
I think we have to really reorient around
a prevention model rather than
a model focused on repair.
- Yeah, I'll agree with that,
but use maybe different words.
I think wellness is the,
and the science of wellness
and achieving wellness
will ultimately be the path
to help address large scale improvements
in population health,
particularly in the United States.
Eileen O'Connor is with me,
she's a former Yale
administrator and leader here.
So we were excited to come here together,
but during Covid we
worked and through Eileen,
helped, worked with the
Yale School of Nursing
and with Yale University on
testing access in our country,
and you might not remember this,
but in March and April of 2020, you know,
actually testing was
not commonly available.
The United States had
rejected through the CDC,
a South Korean testing format
and our own format was faulty.
And the government at the highest level
of our federal government
was actually against testing, right?
And so, you know, that's a good example
of if you sat and asked yourself,
how would you get hundreds
of millions of tests
manufactured, give people
the confidence to use them
just to track their own
health and wellness.
That's the kind of question
that I think we're gonna be
dealing with over and over.
Today at the foundation
when we look to the future,
really coming outta the Covid experience,
where America had the
highest excess mortality
of any nation on the planet in Covid,
which is absurd in a country that puts,
as the president made brief reference
to more than $4 trillion a
year in our healthcare economy,
we think sustained wellness,
the reduction of large
scale chronic disease
that made Americans so
vulnerable to mortality
is going to be the only viable answer.
And it'll be you in this room
that develop the science,
but also the way,
the pathway so that
people can listen here,
engage and participate in
keeping themselves healthy,
so they're not as vulnerable
as we've been in the past.
- Thank you.
Dr. Shah, noting that the
foundation has invested heavily
in solutions related to climate change
under your leadership,
what do you see as the
connection between climate
and human health?
And could you give us some success stories
that you feel the
foundation, or your partners,
or other organizations have had related
to climate and health?
- Well first I heard the president,
your reference to planetary health,
and I'm really glad to hear
that the School of Nursing
is actively engaged in, you know,
understanding the correlation
between planetary health boundaries
and human health boundaries.
I think if you look at climate change,
it's gonna have a few major dislocations
for large scale population health.
The first is we just came out
of a once in a century pandemic.
You can expect those much more frequently
because the pressures
that expose populations
to pandemic threats like zoonotic pressure
will be much, much higher
as the climate changes.
A second is,
we know we're gonna have
much more infectious disease
in many more places than we do today.
That's already very obvious.
So the 50 year history we've
had of a relative decline
in infectious disease mortality,
morbidity is gonna have
sustained upward pressure now
because of climate over
the next bit of time.
A third is heat and heat,
I mean, I was with these women
that are salt flat workers
in the desert in northern
Gujarat in India,
and they're working in 40
degrees centigrade heat.
And it's deadly to do that.
They're already poorly nourished
and they're already the most vulnerable.
And so the combination
of heat and vulnerability
will yield extraordinary consequences.
And the final one that I don't
think most people realize is,
there's gonna be a 30% reduction
in agricultural productivity
caused by a changing climate.
And you know, if you look
at just the path for hunger
and the underlying hidden
hunger or malnutrition
and micronutrient malnutrition
that you all are experts on,
and most people don't know about,
it's gonna make people
much more vulnerable
to all of this in the future.
So I think there are some big threats.
The good news is you're on top of it.
We'll count on your
science and your insights
and your ability to get
people to behave differently,
to keep themselves protected,
but that's why I really believe
your work is more needed
for the next century than the past one.
- I don't think I can add to that answer.
That was just a fabulous answer,
other than to say it is very fortunate
that Yale has a school of nursing,
a school of public health,
a school of medicine,
a school of the environment,
departments in arts and sciences,
and in engineering and applied sciences
concerned with the environment,
concerned with climate change
and beyond all of that,
because it is going to take
a multidisciplinary approach
to solve these problems.
Yes, we all have our particular
emphasis and expertise,
but it's going to be
working across boundaries,
whether those boundaries
are international,
or disciplinary to address these problems.
Sometimes I think as a longtime academic,
that the international boundaries
may be easier to transcend
than the disciplinary ones,
and that would be too bad.
And I think we're trying to model
a more unified approach
here at Yale to addressing,
I think, the most profound
problem of our lifetime.
- So I would like to follow
on what you just shared,
because I know that during your tenure,
Yale has invested campus-wide
in climate issues through the
Planetary Solution Project.
And could you more specifically comment
what role nursing could,
because I know that the interdisciplinary,
you know, collaboration and the challenge
that you just alluded to,
so, and we have a very, you know,
strong platform in the school of nursing
for planetary health.
I would like to hear your thoughts
about how nursing could
play an important role,
in your vision.
- Yeah, I think there's many
roles that nursing can play
in addressing climate
solutions, planetary solutions.
Lemme just give a couple.
First of all,
there is such a strong
emphasis in this nursing school
and at Yale on global health.
You are already all over the world.
You are already collaborating
with investigators,
and clinicians, and
educators all over the world.
And you do that in ways that transcend
some of the political barriers.
So for example,
Yale School of Nursing has
worked in China for a long time.
Politically, we are at a tense moment
between the two countries.
In reality,
climate change is not
addressed without China
and the US working together just can't,
these two enormous economies
have to collaborate.
That's really hard to do right
now at a political level.
But nurses in China and nurses at Yale
can work together on projects.
And you know, when I'm in Washington,
I visit Capitol Hill
and I talk to senators
and members of the house
usually who have a Yale degree,
but they're on both sides
of the aisle, right?
And I say, I bring up China,
I'm just using China as an example.
I bring up China,
most of the time you get
the current view, right,
which is quite negative.
And you get it from
both sides of the aisle.
And then I say,
do you know we have dual
degree programs in China?
We have nurses working in China,
collaborating on capacity
building projects
and educational projects.
We have a center in Beijing
for the university as a whole,
run by the school of management,
et cetera, et cetera.
We have joint degree programs.
I say, do you think we should
pull out of all of that?
Every one of them on both
sides says, no, no, no, no.
Stay involved, please stay involved.
And I think that's because at some level
they recognize that we have
to look toward the future.
We have huge global problems to solve
and we're not gonna
solve 'em in isolation.
So the nurses already doing that.
Yale School of Nursing
is already doing it.
And I guess the other, I'll
just mention one other way.
You are seeing
signs, and symptoms, and patient behavior
often before we know what it
is that we're observing, right?
The way in which nurses
are trained to observe
and to observe whole humans,
and to observe behavior and to observe,
the kinds of measurable signs and symptoms
that we use in healthcare
means that those powers of observation,
that training when put to
use is going to sound alarms
often before we know what's happening.
We know what it is.
And that's kind of a,
what would you call it?
Sentinel function, maybe
a sentinel function.
So bring up sentinel
functions on our centennial.
(audience laughing)
Try to keep that straight and, you know,
but it's a role that
primary care providers
are always going to play.
You will see it even before as a society,
we know what it is.
And that's going to be
very, very important
as we confront new diseases,
or old diseases appearing in new places
as the climate changes.
- Thank you.
So as both of you very eloquently remarked
in your speeches about how
the Covid 19 global pandemic
show the world, the heroic, you know,
impact of nurses and what nurses do,
it was really wonderful for all us nurses
to have that recognition.
But now we are facing a backlash
in not only United States, but globally.
There is a huge shortage of nurses.
And I think that part of
is due to burnout because,
you know, in a couple of
years, the work really,
the nursing work was really devastating,
and so what do you think
we could do to address now
the nursing shortage crisis?
What are the ideas that
you might have for?
- Well, let me mention two, just two.
Nurses who are educated
as leaders, you know,
for the nursing profession,
like here at Yale,
have typically gone to college
and then have gone to graduate school,
and they amass a lot of debt.
At Yale we've been very much
trying over the last decade
to increase access to an education.
And at this university, the highest,
the students with the
highest debt on graduation,
it's not all from Yale, that's for sure.
But the students with the
highest debt on graduation
are our nursing students.
- Wow.
- That has to end.
That has to end.
If we want to see more people
go into the profession.
(audience applauding)
I don't come from a wealthy family,
as you probably figured out from the video
and from my comments about my family.
But it is why we did a scholarship here
in the school of nursing
as the first endowment,
I hope the first among
others that we can do.
And it was really my parents who,
when I was inaugurated as president,
my mother called and she said,
we wanna give you a gift for
becoming president of Yale.
What do you need?
Need a new camera.
(audience laughing)
They got me a camera when
I graduated from college.
(audience laughing)
And I said, I don't need anything.
And I said, well, we wanna get you a gift.
I said, well figure out
something you could do for Yale
and do it for Yale at the
level that you can do it.
My dad was a chemistry professor,
my mother was a nurse, as you heard.
I said, figure out a
level that you can do it.
And they came up with the idea,
we're gonna do a scholarship at Yale
and we're gonna do it
in the nursing school,
'cause we know nurses have a lot of debt
and because mom's a nurse
and that's what they did.
And then we've tried to add more to it
and friends have added
more to it, and the like.
But I think if that,
we don't have to tell,
(audience applauding)
I don't tell that story for your applause.
I tell that story because it's a story
that if we could tell more broadly,
others would follow, others would do,
they would do their own version of this.
They just don't know. They
don't know how high the debt,
as I said, I was gonna talk
about two things we need to do,
but I talked long enough,
so let me yield to.
- I don't have anything
to add beyond that,
except that there should be, you know,
I've always wondered why,
and I think this is a
higher education question,
when there's so much sustained demand
for something that's so
critical to society here
and around the world, why
can't there be more supply?
So, you know,
I don't know whether that means
bigger schools of nursing,
or more schools of nursing,
certainly in global health
and on a global basis,
we desperately need many,
many, many more institutions
that bring what Yale
brings to nursing here
all over the planet.
And you know,
any estimate that you look at
in terms of where people will,
where the needs will be
for society over time,
there's a much greater
share of human labor
that will go into the caring economy
for those that look at
it that way in the future
than in the past
and in a professionalized
compensated manner
as opposed to in the informal economy.
So I just think there's
a supply demand mismatch,
and I don't have enough
expertise to know why,
there aren't so many
more schools of nursing.
Unfortunately, the Rockefeller Foundation,
if we could start schools
for $150,000, we would do it,
(audience laughing)
today we do it all over
the planet, I promise,
but we can't.
- And I'll say one more thing.
When it was February and
certainly March, April, May, 2020,
what happened?
This virus that we didn't know much about
starting to move across the
planet, arrives in the US.
I remember when the first
community transmitted case
in Connecticut arrived when
our students went home for spring break
and we told them stay there.
Nurses went to work,
nurses just went to work.
And they, you know,
we were trying to keep everybody
else out of the hospital.
Nurses went into the hospital
and into the clinics.
And I get a little emotional about this,
when I saw those signs at
Yale New Haven Hospital,
for example, that said heroes work here,
it was an amazing recognition
of what it meant to be
doing that kind of work
day in and day out during this pandemic,
particularly in those early months
when we didn't know it
was gonna kill everybody
who it touched.
It was certainly killing
people, people we knew.
And so, you know,
that heroes work here signs,
just made me think,
how can we make sure that our children,
that our society recognize
what this work is like
day in and day out.
Because if we do that,
not only will it be more
attractive to kids to go into,
but it will, but burnout
will be lowered, right?
People, there's lots of
things that cause burnout
and sometimes it's some very
bread and butter things,
but sometimes it's just,
I wish people knew what it
is like to walk on my shoes.
And people should know what
it was like to be a nurse
in the early days of the pandemic.
- Yes.
- It was to be a hero.
Yet no nurse thought of
themselves as a hero.
They just thought they were going to work.
And it was very impressive.
(audience applauding)
- And we know that the number
of lost lives among nurses
was the highest among all
the frontline, you know,
providers during the pandemic.
And despite your excitement,
President Salovey
about the elimination of,
you know, hierarchical,
and, you know, structure
in the healthcare services
that nurses nowadays really,
you know, can speak up
and if they see malpractice or whatever,
that is not working in the healthcare
delivery by physicians.
But we know that we have
still a long way to go.
And so I wonder your thoughts about
the silly, you know, disparities
of power, pay, you know,
especially in other countries,
I think that we have gone a
long way in the United States,
but generally globally nurses
are usually the lowest paid,
you know, healthcare
professionals and also, you know,
even in the United States
not being able to practice
to the full scope of nurses' capability,
this is a huge even
economic waste of resources.
So what are your thoughts about
how we can really, you know,
change the public, you know, image
of what nurses do and why we
need to really empower nurses
to practice to the highest
scope of their capabilities
and get paid for it appropriately?
(audience laughing)
- Well, I am pleased to
see that this is changing
and I'm not a economist,
or sociologist who can
really answer that questions.
But I will say,
no movement for change has ever happened,
I think without allies.
And I think the allies
are gonna have to be
other healthcare providers
and in particular the ally in recognizing
that nurses who can practice
to their full capability
or the ally that's gonna
have to recognize that
the potential ally who's
gonna have to recognize that
to allow it to happen
is organized medicine.
And it's not a pretty
picture historically.
(audience laughing)
And I, you know,
I don't wanna pick on
anybody or any profession.
(audience laughing)
My mother were alive,
she still would want me to be a doctor.
(audience laughing)
But we can, and there's plenty
of physicians with a
public health orientation,
with a collaborative orientation
who are very much champions of nursing.
But we need more of them to be,
and we need the formal organizations
that represent physicians to be,
because I think both of you
have said in your remarks,
this is part of the solution.
Nurses are gonna be part of the solution.
That's true by the way, in my field,
in the mental health field as well,
in the field of psychology
and psychiatry as well.
- Thank you very much.
I think that now we have
few minutes for questions
from the audience.
And could you please in
order for you to be heard
by everyone, wait for the
microphone to be delivered to you?
- [Audience Member] Yeah, I
have to find the microphone.
- Oh, okay.
(audience laughing)
- It's the one on the podium.
- Oh, under here.
Yeah.
- Thank you. This has been
incredible journey for all of us.
I love the notion of
primary healthcare, disease,
you know, primary healthcare,
disease prevention.
And I think that, and just looking,
it's not just about promoting
health within individuals,
or communities that's necessary,
but structural changes
that need to happen.
And you know, the concept
of political, you know,
constraints that are
affecting people's lives
as well as environmental and social things
that are determining
how many of the marginalized
communities are subsisting,
if you will,
that we need to incorporate those concepts
into the work that we do
in just promoting health in
individual and communities.
And that we have to partner
with all of those elements
to be able to do that.
And Kathy, Gillis,
yes, we were primary care
policy fellows together
back in the 90s,
and that's one of the things
I think is so critical for us
to really start to work on as well.
And thank you for this
incredible presentation.
I appreciate that.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Richard] Hi, Richard
Jennings, class of 79 midwifery.
A little bit off topic, but what do you,
have you considered the role
of guaranteed annual income
as a way to address poverty
in the United States?
- I can take the foundation.
The foundation actually
has done a lot of work
on different forms of
population level interventions
that can address poverty,
child poverty and health improvements.
And one of the shocking
things we learned years ago,
was actually the most effective
healthcare access program
in recent American social policy history
was the earned income tax credit,
the most, which for those of you know,
is a basically cash transfer
to certain working families.
The most effective by far poverty program
in the United States in any recent memory
is the refundable child tax credit.
And our foundation actually supported,
we had this strategy back in 2018
to support advocating for
those two interventions
in red states and blue states.
And so even certain states
that didn't have income tax
could still have a
refundable child tax credit,
or earned income tax credit.
And then when Covid hit,
we actually brought all those
local state grantees together
to Washington and had them
meet with decision makers
in Congress and the White House.
And of course the part
of the Covid response
was the largest social policy experiment
in recent American decades,
which was vastly expanding
those two efforts
as part of providing some form
of basic guaranteed income.
And it was wildly effective,
child poverty got cut in half
the minute that went away,
child poverty doubled.
It's just shocking how
pinpoint accurate that was.
And there are a consortia of foundations
that studied all the impacts
and found people don't waste the money.
People don't use it for
things that are not considered
high value.
It's mostly healthcare,
childcare, support,
so families can be back in the labor force
and nutrition for children.
And so I lean and her teamwork every day
to try to build a more
robust political environment
that can look at the data
and make rational decisions.
We're not quite there yet
as a country, but it is,
and that's not specific
answer on basic income,
but those are the biggest
experiments we have
with any sort of direct cash transfer
that effectively operates as such.
- [Audience Member] Hi, good afternoon.
Back to the wellness.
I think it was the second
question about wellness
in the same manner, how
do we provide incentives?
Because everyone in this room,
and many of us know that
wellness may be the answer,
but if the finances,
if we're in such a model of
disease and symptom treatment,
and that's where the
money is for providers
and people coming out of medical school,
who also have huge debt,
and this is where they're
gonna make their money
and politically pharmaceuticals.
What are your thoughts about systemically,
it's so easy to say wellness,
and I've read the data too,
about preventable diseases,
but what are some real
steps that could be taken
to shift the structure in this country?
- Hmm, well, speaking of someone
who has no particular expertise on this,
other than a little bit
about behavior change
at the individual level, you know,
it providing incentives for individuals
to make lifestyle changes
that are probably built into
their healthcare coverage
would be one level at which to start.
But, you know, when we've
tried that, for example,
I don't know how many of
you are Yale Health members,
but I get my healthcare from Yale Health
when we've tried that,
where you get, you know,
your premiums are lower,
or you don't have to
pay or copay, whatever.
When you agree to a set
of wellness interventions,
it's hard to get people to agree.
They resent the threat to their,
what they believe is their
autonomy and their freedom.
And I think we have to
work on that problem.
And, you know, individual
level incentives are good,
but maybe we should try some group
and societal level incentives
to try to encourage people
to want to engage in those behaviors.
- You know, I could add
two interesting experiments
that I think offer a path
forward. And this could be an area
where we learn from other countries,
but about 20 years ago in Mexico,
they had a program called PROGRESA.
I don't know how many of
you are familiar with that,
but they offered
conditional cash transfers
as President Salovey
just said to, you know,
incentivize certain behaviors.
And they're not dramatically
large cash transfers,
but they encourage, you know,
a certain number of prenatal
visits, and postnatal visits,
and other kinds of preventative
oriented interventions.
And they were extraordinarily effective.
Just, it was a behavioral
economics reality
that they were extremely effective.
And some of those efforts
got scaled around the world,
Bangladesh, Kenya, and we saw,
so we saw such significant results
that we even brought some of
those to Baltimore and Detroit
and places in the US where
they've also been effective,
so I think there's evidence
for that basic approach.
The other effort we just
started is a major partnership
with the American Heart Association
called Food Is Medicine.
And in that context,
insurers have been supporting experiments
to identify whether dietary interventions
can in fact reduce
hemoglobin A one C levels
in pre-diabetic and diabetic populations.
And it's been so effective
that we're scaling that up
and doing a big national
study to explore that
as a basic approach to reducing
the financial pressure.
We spend $300 billion
a year on diabetes care
in the United States, nearly
all of which is preventable.
And it's basically a dietary
disease, as you know.
So, you know, but it is unfortunate
that for all of these types of things,
you're up against some reality. (laughs)
And the reality we're up against is,
we spend trillions of dollars every year
in a very treatment intervention oriented
after the fact medical
system that proved to be
extremely ineffective
during the Covid pandemic
in protecting Americans' lives.
- Yeah, and there's so many
little demonstration experiments
that we can learn from
right here in New Haven,
there is a program to
encourage community gardening
and it teamed up with a program
to encourage healthy eating,
so that the community,
when you went to your community garden,
learned how to grow in an urban setting,
often very urban setting.
When you learned how to grow
things that you could eat,
you then also learned how to
cook them in the healthiest way
and what have you.
So that those are very
small little interventions,
very local, but that's maybe
a good place for it to begin.
I'm also reading right now,
many of you know our professor Tim Snyder.
Tim is the world's expert
really on the history
of Eastern Europe, the Baltic region,
and now Russia and Ukraine.
And many of you have seen him on the news
and his course on the history of Ukraine
is online for anybody to
take and is very, very good.
People tell me that they
appreciate it all the time.
But Tim wrote a little
book a couple of years ago,
I think it's called "Our Malady,"
and it comes out of his
experience of being a patient
with a life threatening disease,
or life-threatening condition.
But being, that's how it starts.
And these were his diaries,
but then he reflects on how
care was delivered to him
all over the world, 'cause
he travels the world,
he and his family.
And the example I just happened to read
in the last couple days
was, I think it was,
it was either the Netherlands or Austria,
I can't remember now,
where you get a little,
when you get your prenatal care,
you get a little passport thing,
that looks like a passport.
And every time you do a prenatal visit,
it gets a stamp in the box for that visit.
After you have a baby, you get
stamps for well baby visits
and the like.
And as you accumulate these stamps,
other healthcare needs that you might have
are more deeply discounted.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And all you have to do
is show your passport
with all these stamps in them.
So it doesn't require great
technological intervention,
but you show your passport
if they're stamped,
when you need something done
in the healthcare system,
it's less expensive for you, right?
It was the simplest kind of intervention.
And apparently everybody
does it because it is simple.
So there you have it,
you're doing wellness prevention
and it's getting you something
in addition to a longer,
healthier life fairly immediately.
- I would like to add to, you know,
in addition to individual incentives
that you both alluded to,
I think that the systemic changes
and also what Dr. Shah
suggested about really learning
from the other countries
that have a much more focus
on prevention and promotion
that has shown how they can reduced,
they have reduced their, you know,
healthcare services costs
and the health outcomes
of are much, much better.
So I think that we need to also
focus more on policy changes
on, you know, political
determinants of health.
We focus a lot on social
determinants of health,
but I think that what we
miss is that, you know,
the root cause of a lot of, you know,
poor outcomes in this country
goes back to the political
determinants of health
and how the decisions that
are made really, you know,
prevents healthcare providers
and healthcare system to,
you know, care more
about the health outcomes
of all the people.
And so thank you, yeah.
Yes.
- [Audience Member] I
wanna thank all of you
for a really inspirational,
your talks and your comments
about past and future.
And to follow up Dr. Emami in terms of,
in the passport issue,
when I was doing research in the UK,
all women in the UK carry their
prenatal record themselves
for the entire pregnancy.
And no backup, you know,
it was this pre-electronic
record, but no backup.
And I remember asking, as
an ethnographer, I said,
well, don't they ever lose it?
And they said, of course not.
(audience laughing)
We lose it much more than they do.
And then they said, why would she lose it?
That's her baby, that's her future.
And so that inevitable trust in the people
that we're caring for is
so incredibly important.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] But
that's not my question.
(audience laughing)
My question is, has been said,
we spend so much money on
healthcare and yet we have,
so our primary providers on
the front lines are limited.
We don't have enough
and we certainly don't
have enough midwives.
And it's not just having
more spaces in schools,
we turn away students
because we don't have
enough clinical sites.
And one of the reasons we don't
have enough clinical sites,
is there's not an investment
in this country in
graduate nursing education.
It's a huge investment
in medical education.
So I'd ask you to say,
what could we do to upend at that?
Because I think it is about
being able to help people
have access to the marvelous
education in so many schools,
and especially at Yale.
(audience applauding)
- Well, I don't know the
answer, but I'd say this,
if there was ever a
moment in recent history
where the basic importance
of nursing, primary care,
massively scaling up diagnostic
capacity in this country,
and democratizing access to
basic health interventions
was seen and felt by everyone,
it was the Covid pandemic.
And I don't actually know,
I'm sure there's expertise in this room,
but it feels like coming out of Covid,
if we really look at why did America have
the most excess mortality
against modeled predictions,
the answer was, America
has the least investment
on a relative basis in good primary care.
We don't value it as much as we should.
We don't pay people as much
as we should in that space.
We don't build infrastructure as much.
We don't even have enough testing capacity
that reaches every community.
And that on a relative basis
is not that expensive to
fix relative to, you know,
the trillions of dollars that we spend
on other parts of the healthcare system.
So this feels like our moment,
you know, to make that case.
- Okay. Hi, I am LaRon Nelson.
I am the Associate Dean of Global Affairs
and Planetary Health.
First wanna welcome and honor Dean Emami
for accepting to lead our school
as we enter into the next 100 years.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
I also want to thank President Salovey
and Dr. Shah for being here to celebrate
the centennial with us and
for offering your thoughts
on the future of nursing at Yale.
My question is for you, Dr. Shah,
I appreciated reading your commentary
that you published last summer online,
which talked about the
Rockefeller's Foundation's interest
in addressing the human
toll of the climate crisis.
As you've already heard,
it's something that we're
trying to prepare nurses,
nurse midwives, nurse practitioners,
scientists and leaders to contribute
to that response as well.
One of the things that we
also think a lot about here
as it relates to the frequency
of extreme weather event
goes beyond the tragic death tolls,
but really to the scale of the
post-traumatic stress effects
that will occur in a global mental health,
in the context of global
mental health infrastructure
that is brittle,
maybe to say to the least
in many lower middle income countries.
We know that the need to
have community-wide wellness
is going to be key to any
real sustainable recovery,
whether it's social, political,
economic and communities
across the planet.
What I'd like to know,
if you could offer us any
thoughts from the foundation
about the role of promoting
global mental wellness
as a strategy for human adaptation
in the context of this
current climate crisis?
- Yeah, what a great, great question.
As would be expected from Yale.
(audience laughing)
As you know, I mean, mental health
is the fastest growing source of morbidity
according to the WHO on a planetary basis.
And if you look specifically
at climate and the estimates,
you know, you have the
number of hungry communities
going from about 700 million
people to 1.4 billion people.
You have 200 million climate migrants.
That's a lot of disruption in
conflict and political strife
and in human wellbeing.
So I think in general,
mental health has to be a much
bigger part of the assessment
and the response kit for nations
that are trying to prepare
for what their public health
infrastructure looks like
in the future.
Unfortunately, right now,
most of the countries
that are most acutely hit
are going through
effectively a debt crisis.
What happened during Covid
was we poured 30 plus percent
of GDP effectively and
monetary and fiscal stimulus
into our economy and it created a floor.
They couldn't do that in 81 countries
that house most of the world's
most vulnerable people.
And as a result, right
now, if you go to Kenya,
62% of their public budget
is paying off interest.
Ghana, I think it's 74%,
and that's true in 40 plus countries.
And so at a time when
they should be investing
in what you're describing
and planning for the future,
they're actually cutting
back on health services,
which is why these
numbers are getting worse
instead of better on basic
things like maternal mortality,
child mortality, and
infectious disease prevalence.
So there's a big financing problem
and it's great to hear that
you have enough of a culture
of interdisciplinary problem
solving that you can, you know,
bring your expertise from here
together with policy teams
that work on those issues.
But it clearly has to be a
very, very big part of planning,
proper planning for public
health in the future
has to be redefined in a
much, much broader way.
- That's global and local.
- Yeah.
- So if you live in New Haven, like I do,
you know, a big part of the city's budget
is servicing debt
- Yeah.
- And making up for underfunded
pensions, pension programs.
And it's only after you pay for those
that you begin to think about, you know,
what could we do to promote the wellness
of of our population?
- [Announcer] Unfortunately, we have time
for only one more question.
So I think I saw somebody
over here. Sorry.
- Careful, careful.
- [Carole] Carole McKenzie,
class of 73 maternal
born and nurse Midwifery.
I live in rural East Texas
as somewhat unenlightened political state,
(audience laughing)
with horrible maternal newborn outcomes.
And I guess my question is,
and also advanced nurse practitioners
do not have full authority.
So if you look at all of those issues,
how do you navigate
the incredibly horrible
political landscape,
without causing a political
brouhaha here, but-
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Turn off the camera.
- Well, let me try.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Let me try, but I'll ask others to help.
- [Audience Member] I
(indistinct) too later.
- Yeah. Well there is,
I actually think there
are potential solutions
on both sides of the political aisle.
So for example, and we try
and do support policy analysis
and advocacy and innovation on both sides
of the political aisle,
but there ought to be a
movement to deregulate
the medical certification rule structure,
so that labor can be rewarded
for the value it can generate,
right? At every level.
And that's a pretty,
if that from first principles,
that's a fairly conservative argument.
And we found some very
conservative Republican partners
would advocate for that with us
alongside some more
progressive communities
that want to eliminate health disparities
and have a different way of
coming at the same problem.
And so, you know,
I mentioned what I mentioned
about the earned income tax credit,
that was actually created by Richard Nixon
in a conservative policy context
as the first negative income
tax in the United States.
And so shockingly there are areas
where you can make progress,
but they do seem to be
dwarfed by the noise
and the noise is only gonna get more noisy
over the course of the next year.
But the underlying point you're making is,
until everyone can be
freed to use their skills
to help their communities be
well and be rewarded for that,
and not be constrained by rules
that are effectively guild structure,
political fighting, you know,
we're not gonna have the workforce we need
unleash the way we need to do it.
And frankly, I personally think
that the application of AI
and other forms of technology
will put even more pressure
on that system,
because you'll find people who believe
they uniquely own some
grand expertise will find
that becomes less and less possible
when your phone can do
what you used to do.
- [Audience Member]
The objective arguments
and the data don't seem to work.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] The Political
landscape doesn't allow,
and I know in the last
hurricane in Houston,
they turned away nurse practitioners
because they didn't have
full practice authority.
They came to help from other
states they could not practice
and they were turned away
that's incredibly irresponsible.
- Very, very sad.
You know, I think a lot of this
is, you talked about Texas,
a lot of this is due
to the incredible political polarization
that we see in our country right now.
Some of the most important
legislative approaches
to healthcare delivery, broadly speaking,
were bipartisan efforts.
I think who in the Senate
sponsored the Family Leave Act?
Who were the two main co-sponsors
of the original Family Leave Act?
Did everybody remember?
- [Audience member] Kennedy?
- Ted Kennedy, that's one.
Who was the other one?
Orrin Hatch?
Okay, right?
So you had one of the most
liberal members of the Senate,
one of the most conservative
members of the Senate.
Why do they come together and do that?
First of all, they were friends.
They actually could have
a civil conversation
with each other.
Second of all they saw
in Family Leave Act,
Kennedy probably saw different things
that produce the same ends or
were produced by the same end.
Kennedy sees a safety net
program guaranteeing jobs,
Hatch sees family friendly legislation,
guaranteeing parent is gonna be home
at least in those early months
or weeks of a child's life.
And so they both can
get behind this program.
Why don't we see that today?
There's a lot of reasons
why we don't see that today.
Two of them are gerrymandered
political districts
that make everybody worried
that they're gonna be challenged
by somebody who's more extreme
in their district than they are,
'cause that's who votes in primaries.
And so they run to the extremes,
reject overtures by the other party,
'cause it looks weak
and because they worry
about their electability,
and maybe the way in
which media is polarized,
and every issue gets a,
has a, you're either force
or against us kind of quality
to the analysis that we hear.
Maybe that will change.
I think we as members of the public
have to kind of demand
that kind of change.
But I think we'll see more
of the kind of legislation
that has led to programs that,
of the kind we would all
like in the health area
if both parties could get behind them,
'cause there is something for
both parties in most of them.
- Yeah.
- And I would like to
add that I think that's,
although the divisive of the, you know,
political climate right
now in this country,
we shouldn't underestimate the power
of community organization and advocacy.
I think that a lot of changes,
transformational changes
that have happened
throughout the history
of the United States
and also other countries, if you look back
they are resulted of the
community engagement,
that community organization
and that I would like to
look at our students here
because I think that nurses
could play an important role.
Part of our job as a nurse is advocacy.
And then we need to really
learn more to be engaged
and to really be the voice of people
who are not having the voice.
And that could also impact the change
in the political climate of this country.
So that is something that
I would like to see more
in our nursing profession and
our next generation of nurses
will definitely do that for us.
- For sure.
(audience applauding)
- First of all,
I would like to thank our special guests
for a very wide ranging rich conversation
and thank you very much the audience
for your thought provoking
questions and your engagement.
Thank you very much.
I think that we all learned a lot
and we are all inspired after
this very rich conversation.
So at this point of time,
I would like to ask
President Salovey to join me
to the podium
because I think that we have
an announcement here and-
- I think you're gonna
make it and I'm gonna clap.
- Okay. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Yes. This is the best part
of this event and also for me
just joining the Yale School of Nursing
and have this privilege and
honor to make this announcement.
Nothing could be better as a
start for my deanship here.
So we would like to make the announcement
about just recently an anonymous donor
has recently finalized a
very, very generous gift
to Yale School of Nursing
in honor of our centennial.
And the gift will directly
impact the students.
We talked about, you know,
the debt and the cost of the education
and those type of gifts are so amazing
and so transformative
for us to be able to,
not only attract the highly
qualified nursing students,
but also really diversify our programs.
So this gift will be an endowment
to provide six full ride
scholarship every year,
starting from this year.
So it's nothing no promise for future,
but right now we can use it.
And this is the largest single
donation we have received
in the Yale School of Nursing.
And the total gift is $11.1 million.
(audience applauding)
So of course I'm very
happy and very excited
about this wonderful opportunity.
But I would like to thank
everyone else beside me,
because I was not a part
of this coming through.
(audience laughing)
So thank you very much.
It was definitely a teamwork
of many years in making
and a lot of people have been
involved and so wonderful,
wonderful opportunity for our school,
wonderful opportunity for our students.
So thank you very much.
- [Audience Member] Mention the matching.
- Yeah, oh yes. Would you
like to mention something?
- So I read,
I was looking at the
dean's script and it says,
and now President Salovey
would like to share some
additional good news.
- And I'm thinking to myself.
(audience applauding)
I wonder what that is.
And I thought it would be
the news about matching.
So as you know, the provost and I,
and Scott Strobel, our
provost is here with us today,
pledged that we would use university funds
to match the first $50
million raised by this school
in the for Humanity campaign.
So that 11.1, is it 11.1?
- Yes.
- Million dollars,
I have to get the math exactly, right?
- Yes.
- That $11.1 Million becomes
$22.2 million for the-
(audience applauding)
- It's amazing. It's wonderful.
- Great, and we hope it inspires others.
And I'm talking to our friends
watching through the power.
- Yes.
(audience applauding)
Yes, yes.
- Of Zoom, of YouTube right now.
- Yes. And and when I
heard about this news,
I just felt, don't feel
any pressure. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
How can I, you know, match
that in my, you know,
we have until 2026 I
think to end the campaign.
- That's right.
- And hopefully we are going to,
this major gift will
inspire a lot of our friends
and donors too.
- It sure will.
And all joking aside, we
couldn't be more grateful
to our anonymous donor for this,
- Yes.
- incredible act.
And these are dollars
that will go very far
in the School of nursing and
will help with that debt issue
that we were talking about earlier today.
So thank you very much
and thank you to anyone
who is able to contribute.
We recognize not always at that level,
(audience applauding)
but in any way.
- Thank you.
- Thanks very much.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
So I would like to close
our celebration today
with a round of applause
for Centennial committee.
Please join me to thank them for helping.
(audience applauding)
Centennial Committee represents
a wide range of volunteers
to really help and worked very
hard tirelessly in 18 months
to planning and organizing all the events,
the celebrations and everything
that is going to happen
throughout this year.
And some of those amazing volunteers
are today with us in this room.
So I would like to ask you to stand up,
to be recognized if you are here
as I am reading your name.
Janene Batten.
Helen Burst.
(audience applauding)
Elizabeth Doyle.
- [Audience Member] Oh my goodness.
- Melissa Galinato.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Nakia Black-Geter..
(audience applauding)
Holly Powell Kennedy.
Michelle Koss.
(audience applauding)
Mel Kosturko.
Nancy Kraus.
(audience applauding)
Gail McCulloch.
Erin Morelli.
(audience applauding)
Caroline Piselli.
Heather Reynolds.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Marcia Thomas.
(audience applauding)
And David Vlahov.
I also would like to thank Michelle Morgan
and Tipsy Pix crew
for their videographic services here today
and HP Live for their broadcast support
and our event manager,
Michelle Koss again,
for making all the
behind the scene magics.
(audience applauding)
I'm also grateful to Hillary
Dooley, Julia Pafford,
Mike Regan, and Taylor Testone
on our office of development
and Alumni relations
for all the contributions that made it
to today's very successful day for us.
(audience applauding)
And last but not least,
I would like to thank
both our special guests.
Thank you very much for carving out
of your very, very busy time
to come here and have
this wonderful discussion.
This is a great initiation
of our yearlong celebration.
So Dr. Shah, if you join me now here,
so that I could present with
you a small token of here,
our appreciation for your time here.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much. Exactly.
- Oh wow.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
(gentle music)